buongiorni simo bongiorni simo mi
presento sono alessandro iii vani in
arte testa di cazzo testa di cazzo che
già come nome a due chiave di lettura
ossia essendo il mio nome su instagram
mio profilo e la mia testa quello che
vedete è la testa di cazzo è un po come
l'insulto perché sono molto autoironico
mi piace prendermi in giro io vengo da
un paesino in friuli di 7000 anime dove
gli orizzonti sono sconfinati ma sono
solo naturali dove se vuoi fare arte
molto molto molto difficile perché
comunque se sei giovane c'è il classico
legame al passato e non si vede tanto in
avanti e ho sempre avuto la necessità di
esprimermi in famiglia questo fa ridere
c'è un'azienda di pompe funebri
quindi io da quando sono piccolo sono
sempre stato abituato ad andare da mia
mamma in ufficio a bere il caffè alle
pompe funebri
quando mia nonna veniva a cena da noi mi
diceva satu cui caliamo artway ve lo
traduco perché friulano sai chi è morto
oggi fa ridere
l'importante di questa cosa qua è che mi
ha fatto capire che ho iniziato ad avere
un rapporto molto realistico con il
concetto di morte ed avendo io una
malattia che è l'arte perché per me è
una malattia l'arte ho iniziato a capire
che volevo fare arte per lasciare un
segno del mio passaggio sulla terra
perché nessuno sceglie di nascere ma
tutti possono scegliere come vivere e io
voglio vivere lasciando il mio sogno
ho avuto un percorso scolastico un po
travagliato dalle superiori in poi la
prima l'ho fatta due volte perché era
divertente
ho studiato grafica e alle superiori mi
hanno forgiato due grandi concetti less
is more ossia poco è abbastanza e il
flusso di coscienza che sono i due
concetti su cui adesso si basa la mia
arte dopo le superiori in un momento un
po di crisi ho iniziato a provare
un'università un'altra e un'altra ancora
l'ho mollata e tutte e tre primo anno
perché non riuscivo a esprimermi non
trovavo che in questa università
nonostante fossero artistica ci fossero
le vie perché io potessi esprimere la
mia
allora noi mentre mentre non mollate
ho detto devo portare un po di pagnotta
a casa e ho iniziato il mondo del
tatuaggio sempre stato super affascinato
da questo mondo perché è l'arte che
rimane per tutta la vita con le persone
sempre tornando al discorso che nessuno
sceglie come nascere o di nascere
nessuno sceglie il corpo in cui nasce è
perché ha molto a tuo agio perché una
decorazione perché tutto il tuo corpo
puoi decorare puoi comunicare quello che
pensi
ho sempre disegnato ogni lezione alle
superiori
è stato un disegno non avevo mai fatto
punti zero punti iscritti ogni direzione
un disegno
finite le superiori finita l'università
sto facendo la vendemmia
la vendemmia perché appunto era il
lavoro stagionale
e siccome io quando disegno il disegno
dove finirlo proprio per il concetto del
flusso di coscienza esce e deve essere
finito non riuscivo più a finire disegni
perché arriva un trattore dopo l'altro e
li lasciavo metà era iniziato a provare
a scrivere cosa che non ho mai fatto in
vita mia ma è reputato uno scrittore
insomma che non scrive la poesia mi
iscriverò frasi sconce frasi dirette
mangia come parli e mangiavo male parli
come mangi mangiava male
è stato pubblicarle soprattutto perché
io sono sempre stato super attivo sui
social la figata dei social e che ti
permettono di mostrarti di comunicare
per me è sempre stato un curriculum non
lo vedo con il profilo di far vedere me
tutte cose per un curriculum
e
pensate pubblicare frasi 10 frasi al
giorno ogni giorno adesso che profilo
conto 820 posti circa quindi in tre anni
sono 8mila frasi
quando iniziato pubblicarle però proprio
per il discorso della semplicità di
queste frasi ho deciso che volessero
essere robert semplici dirette quello
che io penso nel mio cervello deve
uscire per la prima volta ho visto che
la gente iniziava a condividerle a
comunicare attraverso quello che
scrivevo detto wow non era mai successo
che vi design sempre impegnato nel
dettaglio fa il disegno più bello che
poi non era mai successo io ho capito
una cosa ho capito che è bellissimo
parlar di se stessi
ho tirato fuori quei lati che non sapevo
di avere soprattutto una cosa che mi è
piaciuta tantissimo dello scrivere e che
volevo rimanere per terra non avevo la
pretesa di fare il poeta ma avevo
proprio voglia di rimanere per terra
underground una scrittura un po più
giovane
scrivendo mi son reso conto appunto di
quanta gente condivide essere quello che
scrivevo che dicevo
la cosa molto bella è proprio il fatto
che mi sono reso conto che i vostri
coetanei miei coetanei si rivedessero in
quello che dicevo e yahoo penso a te
però allo stesso tempo vedendo questa
cosa se da un lato mi galvanizza va dall
ato mi lasciava po di malinconia perché
dicevo sono cose che pensano tutti
la gente mi diceva sei la voce dei
pensieri che non riusciamo a dire
ma se c'era i pensieri dovresti riusciti
ad
e poi ho iniziato a riflettere
riflettere misero perché quanti di voi
hanno dedicato una frase una parola
una canzone che qualcun altro
chiunque
è iniziato comunicare per me stesso
scrivendo 10 frase del giorno iniziato a
scoprire frasi lati di me stesso che non
sapevo esistessero
e allora ho detto cup perché nessuno lo
fa perché gli altri usano le mie frasi
per comunicare se stessi è quella che mi
lasciava malinconia
bellissimo perché per l'amore ripeto
c'era gente che si immedesimava in
quello che facevo
però lo stesso tempo
sono pensieri talmente tanto semplice
che puoi dirlo tu
appunto
e io voglio lasciarvi con un concetto
grande
non bisogna essere
non bisogna aver paura di essere banali
non bisogna avere
la vena poetica
non bisogna
essere artisti per comunicare se stessi
bisogna essere se stessi le parole sono
fortissime soprattutto quando sono
semplici la grafica ma l'ha insegnato la
grafica ha insegnato che è molto più
forte una grafica semplice che una piena
di elementi
le comunico per me stesso per terapia e
per autonalisi 25 anni non sapevo tutti
i lati di me che ho scoperto scrivendo
e volevo lasciarvi appunto con questa
frase che secondo me non è più che un
insegnamento ma è un consiglio per i
giovani perché poi dopo due anni di
lockdown queste cose abbiamo perso tanto
la capacità di esprimerci esprimiamo
attraverso parole dardi altri e secondo
me la gente si esprime con le parole
degli altri perché ha uno schermo
davanti
perché c'è quella sottile quel sottile
velo che ti porta a dire non l'ho fatto
io quindi la parola è meno pesante e più
leggera posso nascondermi dietro al tar
o di qualcun altro e sono dell'idea che
nascondersi dietro le polari qualcun
altro sia limitante
bisogna sforzarsi di usare le proprie
parole bisogna sforzarsi di creare il
proprio pensiero bisogna sforzarsi
soprattutto di capire cosa si vuole dire
perché poi sempre tornando al discorso
del passaggio sulla terra e solo
comunicando solo parlando che voi
potrete capire e potrete restare nella
testa della gente e nel cuore e quindi
questo è il mio consiglio
sforzatevi più che potete di parlare con
le vostre parole
approfittate leggete ispiratevi ma usate
le vostre parole perché le vostre parole
saranno le uniche che saranno vostre le
parole di altri rimarranno sempre parole
di grazie
soluzione
[Musica]